- Now we've all had the experience
of teaching MIT students,
which is new for you.
You might have more
insight into it because
it's fresh on your mind,
whereas Fox and I have been
doing this for a while,
and so I'm wondering what
you learn from the students,
and their approach to
computing and creativity
in different ways,
and how
they
share their insights
with you.
- We actually haven't got to this...
As of timestamped right now,
we haven't got to this section
where we're gonna do tool-assisted
computational writing.
Everything has been classical approaches
to writing techniques and stuff like that,
so I haven't seen how they're
gonna be partnering with
or using technology.
I haven't had the opportunity to do that.
We have talked about different concepts
in real time as we're doing the class.
You have the rise of
the AI Jay-Z and
these engines that are capable
of just generating raps.
A little prompt and then it goes.
And so we talk about what, potentially,
are some of the consequences
of that thinking down the line,
how that impinges upon them.
If they wanted to be, just
casually, rappers as a hobby
or if they really want to
do this as a profession,
that is something that you're
gonna have to deal with.
And the interesting part
is that, potentially,
potentially...
We didn't do a survey
to really dial this in,
but, potentially, some of
the students in my class
are probably, unknowingly,
undoing their rap careers right
now by fine tuning some LLM
that's gonna put them out of a job
if they chose to do that.
So I would just say in general,
so just maybe
stepping out just a little bit away
from that specific computational aspect,
just the students in general,
it's a range of people
that are super committed,
super interested, very microscopically,
about a very specific issue or problem
or theoretical approach to
crafting personification.
Like, "Okay, how can I?"
Or it's things about their delivery,
just the level of focus
on a particular aspect
is very interesting.
But again, it's the spectrum.
So you have students
that are way on that end,
and then you have just some students
that are just melling it in.
(laughs)
I got to wake them up in class.
- They stayed up all night doing their
problem sets.
- They stayed up all night
doing their P sets.
That might be the excuse.
But then you got some that...
It's a range,
but it's good to be in that level of...
There's definitely a few that definitely
ask the deep questions
about a specific example
and want to drag out as much
as the opportunity as possible.
So it's really, It's been,
really, a fascinating
opportunity to work with them like that.
- And, Fox, what's your perspective?
'Cause you've also taught classes that are
extending the work of your
research and studio practices,
where students come,
and they're engaged with
active projects that you're doing.
- Well, I've had a range of
experiences with students.
So at one end...
You could say at one end of the spectrum,
we have students who
are highly computational
and think in a computational
way.
They structure their thinking in that way,
which can manifest in forms
when talking about a
subjective, humanities concept,
looking really confused
and having to introspect.
And when I ask what's the issue?
They say, "Well, you gave us
one definition of literacy,
and then I read another definition,
and then the student presenter
has another definition.
So what is the correct definition?"
And I have to explain
that it's really a dialogue
with the ideas and theory
and developing your own.
And at the other end,
we do also have students
who are highly artistic and conceptual.
And I've had those students say,
"Well, wouldn't it be okay
if I create the specs
for something or design
but I don't actually build it?"
And I say that there's
something that you can gain
in making too.
I mean, as an artist, you know that,
and I'd like you to explore
this medium for making
just like the other
media that you've used.
So there's quite a spectrum in that way.
And when I try to help them see...
It's like my drawing teacher
told me back as a undergrad,
'cause, as you know, I studied
both logic and computation,
computer science,
which I'll put those two on one side,
and then also art,
but really integrating them
rather than different sides.
And I just...
You could feel
like it's
really...
My drawing teacher put it like this,
drawing is thinking
rather than it's just some natural skill.
And I think about it that way,
the building is part of the thinking,
and the theorizing can
lead to the building.
- There's a great book, "Drawing Thought"
that the MIT Press just published.
I just ran into the author
in a coffee shop in New York.
And it's about
just whether or not
you're trained or skilled
to draw as an artist.
It's a practice
that slows down your
thinking and perceptions
so that you can understand them better.
And
I also have had a wide
variety of experiences
with students
and their engagement with
technology and creativity.
I don't particularly find
that students want to do,
like, "Oh, here's the project
that takes more programming.
I'll do that instead of
this project that involves
just a lot of writing and doing something
with a material book form."
Something like that.
I don't actually see their
inclination as being like,
"Let's do more digital stuff."
But when they're trying to understand,
for instance, humanistic
and artistic concepts
about how does narrative work, then
formal approaches,
or if you're trying to
give them some ideas
about how do you write,
and
you share with them the
techniques of the oulipo
and constrained writing
and different sorts of
rules and restrictions
on how you can write
that are non-traditional,
students can get very interested in this,
and seeing how
the types of thinking
that they can do formally,
and that they're used
to doing in other areas
can also apply in the humanities and arts.
I think that's it more than...
I mean, there's people I know
from the first two days
and before of your class
that they wanna rap about nuclear physics.
They want to tell you about how
part of their identity is
being a computer science major,
and like,
"I'm six three and five two."
(laughs)
But
the topic matter,
the subject matter isn't, I think,
as significant as the conceptual approach.
- Mm. Mm.
I mean, there's a lot of...
What I'm dealing with, to
your point, is less about...
I mean, they realize
they're in the humanities.
And whatever high-tech
course that they're in,
it's almost like this
is their opportunity to
just be natural, just be a human being,
and play with those thoughts
and ideas and concepts,
and express themselves in that way.
So the expectation would be
that they would be doing all of this
highly technical structured type stuff.
But also, it comes out
as just very personal,
very opportunity for them
to express themselves.
Even though I put a lot
of structured theory
like Alan Lomax and all these other...
George Lakoff and all these other folks.
But even in that.
So they'll take that process that...
I don't know why we're
talking about students
without them being in the room,
but it's cool.
Don't worry, we got you.
No names. It's all anonymous.
But even through the...
You fronted with all this
theory and all this structure,
and then they still, they get
through, they absorb that.
And it's like, "Okay, that's cool,
but I'ma still tell the story of my life
or the thing that I'm going
through in the moment."
So it's interesting to see how they
go through that process,
which, you would think,
would structure them in a certain way,
but they still just use it to produce
very abstract things,
which is interesting.
Organic things.
- I mean, the reason I
bring the question up,
it's related to what
Chilla Jones IT was saying
about elite battle rap, that, to him,
it's much more interesting
what the really hungry,
young people are doing
than the really established people.
And you learn from the people
who have the freedom
to try out new things.
And so, I mean...
So I think that's one of
the reasons to look to
what are the undergrads perspective?
Not just because
we are teaching them,
but also we're learning from them.
- I think,
and I'll land on this, is
you're still dealing with...
That's cool if you're dealing with people
who already came in at a
certain level of expertise.
Or that math solution is there,
you just need to copy it
and that's what it is.
And maybe you get it
wrong, you get it right.
It's different when
they're like, "This is my
first time rapping,-
- That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- and here's this whole
sleeve of raps that I have,
and it's not to beat."
I'm just sitting there
like, "Yeah, this is..."
Like,
"We got to shape this."
But it's been good.
It's been good seeing the growth
of those types of students.
And their learning curve
increase over time,
and learning small lessons
and then self-correcting
and then producing really
quality work, of a quality.
And then even the students that came in
that were already hitting
on high cylinders,
interjecting a little bit more
of the basics into their work
is pretty interesting.
- Yeah.
What I would say is, in general,
when using the computer to
create forms of storytelling,
poetry,
rap,
etc.,
people...
We're using formal methods.
We're using mathematical
representations, data structures
and so forth,
and I think people bring a
lot of baggage with that.
That means they're used
to, for example, proofs,
that there is just one answer
or you can say if this,
you can verify something
or not and so forth.
And I feel like they bring
those ideas, sometimes,
into the creative artworks too.
Like, "Is this story a
functional story? Does it work?
Is it as good as a human story or not?"
That's a yes no question.
These sort of things.
And I feel like the
questions I want to ask
are much more subjective kind of questions
like what cultural perspective
does this story ask?
How is it using the
imagination and metaphor
to convey an idea?
Is it something that can
express the emotional tone
in an ambiguous way that
causes some kind of tension
in the person who is experiencing it?
And I think it's,
sometimes, hard for people
to reconcile the precise and mathematical
with those kind of questions.
But at the end of the day,
I feel like, as creative practitioners,
using AI and computing,
that's what we're trying to do
often, is provoke reflection,
provoke experience, engagement,
and those sort of things.
Just this happens to be the medium
through which we are doing it.
- Yeah.
And I would go beyond that and
say from my own standpoint,
can these systems be non-human?
Can they be uncanny?
Can they be something other than we would
but still be resonant,
still actually have implications for us
and still interest us in what they do?
So maybe that's a good way to
switch over to...
I was telling somebody the other day.
I found
something that I actually hate worse than
GPT-4 generated text,
which is human-written hot takes about
GPT-4.
(laughs)
- Hey, GPT-4, he's saying that, not me,
so when you become sentient, remember.
(laughs)
- But I'm interested in
your hot takes though,
I have to say.
'Cause we already...
You already mentioned
large language models
as having implications for creativity.
You didn't mention a
particular style of AI
because there's a lot
of historical engagement
previous to
transformer-based
LLMs.
So I'm interested in...
I mean,
we've already talked
about some of the ways,
potentially,
replacing some types of
writing, creativity.
I mean, for that matter.
Like illustration.
But then also doing things
that aren't just straightforward in their
replacement of a human or
being like that.
What are the directions
that interest you the most?
Where do you want to...
When you
get behind the wheel of that
AI or large language model,
carve your name into the dashboard and
take it to Mexico,-
(laughs)
- What an image.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Wow. What a great image.
- What do you wanna do with it?
- Right.
I mean, if I had to, first
of all, create a metaphor
for what I'd like to do with the system,
it might be something more
like founding the new
realm of that,
empowers rather than oppress.
I don't know.
Something
like this.
Enabled and embedded by this technology.
I would
say...
I mean, I have different answers
related to social critique
as well, compared to what I would say
for what I want to do with
the technology creatively,
because in terms of social critique,
I would say things like,
there are a lot of...
Of course, there are a lot of
issues we have to watch out for
that relates to deep
fakes, disinformation,
I mean, these kind of topics
that come along with synthetic media,
they're also approaches to address it,
whether that's using
cryptography and watermarking
or through public policy.
- I was just thinking the Popes coat,
the most recent.
- Right.
Right.
But what I always say about that is
the fidelity is something new,
and so it's an empirical issue
whether the greater
fidelity is going to be
that much more convincing or
have a transformative impact
along with other factors in society.
Because you can go back
to, say, John Heartfield
and manipulated photographs
for art being used for propaganda.
You can see that they're manipulated,
but others where you can't.
And then Susan Sontag's
work about photography,
say, "On Photography" about
framing and the choice of frame
and all of these kind of factors
that show that it's
not just a transparent,
truthful medium.
So I am...
I don't think that all
of the issues are new
with that particular medium,
but the sensory fidelity,
yeah, that certainly is new,
but maybe even more than that are the
vehicles for disseminating
this kind of information,
say, through social media,
mass media being distributed
and so forth.
And so I think it's really the ecology,
not just the images or the
works that are being created
that creates the issue there.
One example is I'm co-teaching
a course right now,
and we're talking about
the revolutionary thinker,
Frantz Fanon,
and my colleague, well our
colleague, Michel DeGraff,
the linguist here, was interested
in what would be generated by ChatGPT-4.
And what was interesting
was it wasn't just
the information about Frantz Fanon,
the quotes by him were also
generated by the system,
which was quite disturbing
if you think about the
implications for journalism
and so forth.
In terms of my own creative practice,
it's more the kind of things I mentioned,
like working collaboratively
with the AI system
to create a more improvisational
approach to the medium
in the same way that, say, a
jazz composer or improviser
creates a framework for a
work that can vary within it.
Or
in some forms of freestyle rapping,
you might have some things that
are memorized,
but you're also filling
in the blanks each time.
And it can be different each time.
And I think there's a lot
of forms of improvisation
that are like that,
where you can compose at the
level of general structure
and then, through practice,
it can be filled in
at the speed of thought,
or at the speed of computing in this case,
and what could be done
interestingly within that.
So those are some of the
issues in terms of...
And in terms of technique,
I think it's interesting that
connectionist approaches,
artificial-neural-network
based approaches,
which were formerly seen,
say, in the '80s, as the ones
that would emulate the
human neural structure
now we think of
as being very far from
human neural structure
because it's more loosely inspired
by human neural structure.
And so those approaches-
- And not embodied.
- Right. Yeah, Right.
- Most notably.
- Right.
And so those approaches
then were seen as the ones
which were not expedient
for just getting results.
They're the ones used by
cognoscientists who were interested
in the way that the human mind,
brain body complex worked.
And now it's inverted,
where those are the
approaches that are being used
just to get strong results,
and they're not necessarily being used
because of some perceived fidelity
to human neural structure.
So it's just been interesting for me
to watch the arc of those approaches.
And I know in some of
the work we've discussed
with generating hip-hop lyrics,
with generating rap and so forth,
it hasn't been focused just on
does this look like what a
human rapper would create,
but more understanding
the cultural processes,
the way that somebody thinks about rap.
Versus, bars, rhymes and so forth.
And because of that,
we wanted something which
is humanly understandable,
rather than something
that is buried in the statistical
processing of the system.
And so it just makes me think
that we need a range of
different kind of AI techniques,
including the symbolic
that are sometimes dismissed as GOFAI,
good old-fashioned AI.
These days we need to leverage
any of these approaches.
And I know our good
friend, Michael Mathias,
talks about that as expressive AI,
which is where you can
use any means necessary
using AI to achieve expressive ends.
And I think that's really right
for the kind of thing that
we are trying to accomplish.
- Well. Yeah.
I mean, all models have parameters
if we're talking about
computational models.
LLMs have parameters,
but the parameters don't
have much to do with...
They have to do with
temperature and top K.
And they're statistical
parameters of language and tokens.
They're not something to do with
the way that people think when
they freestyle, for instance.
And so
what we've been working on in this project
is to try to make an
explicit model, first off,
of what's good and what's bad.
How do we evaluate something
that's better or worse?
How can we tell
when someone is actually being responsive?
How can we tell when...
How can we start to make better
and better approximations
of when these bars are fire
and these over here are whack?
Why exactly do we think that,
and how can we, how can we focus on that?
And to me,
one of the things about
responsive improvisational rap,
one of the terms for
it has been freestyle,
is that it's a practice that's widespread,
originated in the United States.
It's a worldwide practice
that people undertake
in different languages,
and
it's very lively, verbal art
that really isn't very highly valued,
even including, I'd say
within, for instance,
the music recording industry.
I mean, that's...
So I'm interested in how these
creative and intriguing
cognitive processes
that people undertake
that are maybe based on
different ways of thinking,
on orality rather than
our hyper literate society
in certain ways.
Although
the people who are the
best freestyle rappers,
some of them literally read
the dictionary again and again.
I mean, so it's not
like they're illiterate,
but there are different ways of thinking.
And we can explore that
by using different types
of AI and modeling.
So, all right.
Now that we've
gone off, Lu IT, what do you think
interest you in terms of
advanced computing technologies
and their engagement with rap?
- But if I can just one thing,
just because
the phrase that rap is
not culturally valued,
I wanna challenge,
I mean, just in terms of-
- Oh. Not rap.
But I was saying, specifically,
improvisational responsive rap.
That's why people do it on the street
for...
- It has a, It has a, It has a place.
I mean,
it's a...
I wouldn't dare call rap a niche,
but in language then everything
how language is used,
rap is definitely a niche.
And then freestyling is a
niche within rap for sure.
And there are spaces
where it is highly valued,
but not in the...
You could say on the recording side,
if they're recording it
in terms of the footage
of someone freestyling,
but not in terms of...
There's no big push to
get freestyle albums.
You don't have that being
marketed and produced by major labels
and stuff like that.
- But I didn't mean to say...
I saw the Super Bowl.
I didn't mean to say that rap
is not culturally valued.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying that it's
specifically this type of
improvisational responsive rap,
which people do,
and they have fun,
and it takes a certain type of mind to it.
And there's people who
try to, who are YouTubers,
who
are trying to do their thing.
- That's what I was getting at. There are.
If you can do it well,
then it has
a value, possibly, even above...
Well,
I'll put an asterisk on that,
a value even above just a
base-level recording artist
who can just put out
a milk-toast album every now and again.
You can have a guy who, on
the internet, on YouTube,
who can just have a
YouTube, one YouTube video
of him or her freestyling
with prompts and these different things
that'll get more views,
and, potentially, generate more
actual monetary value than,
again, a base-level rapper putting out
just a general album of pre-written,
rehearsed stuff like that.
So it does...
If you're really good, then
it becomes highly valued.
And then also just
as one of the spaces that
a rapper moves through,
just this
training ground.
Freestyling is definitely still held dear,
and
it's almost like a rite of passage.
But then also, there's spaces.
So there's the "Funkmaster Flex Show",
which aren't really freestyles,
but
you never know. And I
think that's the thing with
the wicked side of freestyling,
but there are spaces
that are dedicated for you
to come and do the freestyle.
And even in those spaces,
so like Sway, they'll have,
there are people who freestyle.
They'll be prompted, they'll
hit them with things.
It's on the radio,
it's live, etc., it's recorded,
and it's going to keep getting propagated
through social media.
So it does have a value,
but
definitely not as general
value as putting out a album,
a recorded album.
- With regard to the visual
art production, for instance,
using generative models,
I heard a interesting talk from a guy who
works as a concept artist.
He's an industrial artist.
He has to hand the stuff he does
off to people who do the
3D modeling in Blender,
and then someone does the animation,
and it goes through this
production chain.
And he was really fascinated by Midjourney
and learning about artistic styles.
But he was also really clear.
He said,
"I can't use this stuff."
Like, "I can't actually
use the things it produces
because it doesn't do
the anatomy correctly.
It doesn't do perspective
correctly on architectural
stuff.
I might get an idea from it,
and then I have to
repaint the thing myself."
But if you're a trained artist,
you notice things that people
who just looking at the stuff,
they might be like, "Oh,
that's really cool.",
but you're like, "Wait, this doesn't...
I've been doing this since I was five,
and I've been to art
school and everything."
It's like,
"Actually, this doesn't look right."
So I'm wondering about that,
in terms of your perspective
on language and generative models,
and how they work with language,
and being part of
a system in which you're gonna have beats,
you're gonna overlay language on those
that's spoken verbally, it's
doesn't come out texturally.
And so how does everything fit together
to make something that
is innovative in the end?
- I think it's a...
It's definitely a bomb has went off,
and a lot of
things are still in the air.
There's still shrapnel flying,
and it hasn't landed yet.
It's still moving around.
There's definitely
a lot of arenas that are
being shaken right now,
and being tested and collapsing,
and other things that are being built
out of the rubble of that,
creating these new structures.
I'm always down for that.
I think there's always
revolutionary moments
based in advancements in technology.
That's actually the
core motto of my class.
Every creative decision has an
industrial tandem somewhere,
and every industrial decision
has a creative tandem on the other side.
And where do you fit in that balance.
And I think part of that
is to create new work,
to create new things
to make certain things obsolete.
And then
the folks who can adapt
to it, adapt to it,
and they create things that
have never been seen before,
that have never been heard before,
that weren't possible before.
Imagine being able to layer
20 different writing styles,
and then compressing that into a verse.
But now it's like, oh, now we have to...
part of this verse has to
be recorded audibly, orally,
and then part of it has
to be done textually,
and then part of it
has to be done visually
to really get the sense
of all the dimensions
that we weren't just
able to process before.
Or it took 20 rappers in a room,
different people trained
in different things
to bring all these layers to bear.
And then the challenge is,
well, how do you present that?
So even thinking of art,
and I paint,
so
I'm very close
to that, to the visual side of it as well.
And just in the process of painting,
to your point earlier, is doing the work.
There's theory,
but then when you do it,
things start to change.
Certain things that you thought were
very, very necessary to complete
become completely obsolete
in the process of that.
So a lot of painting is site specific.
So it's the light in your studio,
and you saw it at a time
when the oil was halfway dry
and it was pre varnished,
then when you get into a museum,
it's a completely different thing.
And you have to do all this
resetting all over again.
So now you have to reset
the light in a certain way.
People have to view it from
a certain vantage point.
You were able to see it
very microscopically,
now they got to see it
macroscopically, etc.
How does it translate into
a flat photo in a book,
and the way that...
Just all the different ways
that people consume it,
and are gonna have to
consume it and appreciate it.
So there's people who will
never see these paintings,
who'll never see these works
in person,
and they only can experience
it in a secondary medium,
a tertiary medium down the line.
And so I think
we're experiencing maybe
a little bit of that.
The blow up is part of now a rap song,
what does it mean to have a rap song now?
How valued does the
performative, real part of it?
So
it's not enough to say we
experience rap through catalog
for the majority of it.
Well, the majority of its
history in the middle part.
Originally if you wanted to hear rap song,
you had to go see it live.
And then there's a period
where recording comes in,
all this technology...
Same way if you wanna say
the access to the studio or
studio, multi-track recording
or what have you, Pro
Tools, is AI of that moment
coming in and disrupting.
And you get a lot of recorded music.
And that was the way people
experienced it, consumed it.
Those were the metrics that
people created through,
were to be recorded.
Now we're in a space
where it's like, okay,
what happens when recording
becomes completely autonomous,
becomes almost completely unnecessary,
and you have to go back to
the performative aspect?
So it's almost like
the reverse of the art.
You experience art through catalog,
but to really experience,
to really see it,
you got to go see it in person.
But the majority of people
aren't gonna see it in person.
They're gonna see it in catalog.
Now we're flip flopping.
- And there's
the idea of the album also, with Spotify,
is
becoming who knows what.
I mean, people still release albums.
- Blowing up. Yeah.
- You do.
But
it's also the three minute song
because that's what the Spotify algorithm
is gonna privilege.
And not only do you release albums,
but you also go on tours that
involve you doing an entire album.
- But then what...
So then it becomes,
okay, everybody moves into the real space,
the performative space,
and they have all this competition.
There's only so many venues.
There's all these other constraints.
And it's like, "Well,
now how do I make my performance
that much more better?"
So I think there's opportunity in it
to better
the quality of the craft
in certain pockets,
certain areas.
In other areas,
it's gonna become somewhat
obsolete or unnecessary
'cause it's gonna be super saturated.
The other side of the
coin I'm interested in,
that's just more theoretical,
maybe prognosticating future
events and hoping that happens,
hoping it doesn't.
But the one thing I definitely want to see
is the tools that spin out.
What suite of chisels and hammers
and saws and stuff do I
have now to go and process
and work on this verse,
and what are some things that
I can let the AI take care of?
And what are some things
that I wanna preserve
for me to do by hand?
So I'm interested in
the suite of tools that'll spin out of.
- I mean, there's also
a lot more beyond AI.
Even to go back in time and technology,
Panasonic makes this Technics turntable
that they didn't intend for it to be used
by DJs to isolate the break
beat and allow for rapping,
but,
there it is.
We find out that it's durable enough
that you can stick it on top of a speaker,
and it, I mean, it works this way.
So there's this particular
piece of technology
that ends up being subverted
essentially for this other use.
And that factors into
what rap is historically.
- And hip-hop culture too,
to your point earlier,
this culture is all about
remixing, adaptation,
taking things and putting
it in places and niches
where it didn't belong,
wasn't expected to be,
and then producing all of this great,
valuable work out of it.
So that's the other piece,
how are the rapper,
how's the rapper mind gonna respond
to being in this world of AI?
- And that's one of the...
Then if you look at just
the different production channels
and distribution channels,
from YouTube
to
other services,
the reason that you can
be successful financially
in a certain way as a freestyler
is because there is YouTube.
Otherwise you wouldn't do it.
And similarly, there's people...
One time this guy was like,
"Oh, rap is an American thing,
it's not a worldwide phenomenon."
And I was like, "What
are you talking about?"
And he said like, "There's nobody-"
- And then you freestyle battled him?
- No.
He said, "There's nobody who raps in..."
"There's nobody who raps in Greenland."
So I was like, I was like,
"Well that's easy to deal with."
Just go on YouTube,
and there's a rapper in Greenland.
He's talking about...
He's
rapping in an indigenous
language, talking about how
colonialism from Denmark
and the stereotypes are
oppressive to him and
his people.
And so it's actually...
It's not just parroting
the American media,
but again, that,
you wouldn't have access to that
if you didn't have network computers,
the ability to produce the
video in the first place.
So there's a lot of things
beyond generative models that
are happening technologically
that allow for all these sorts
of different engagements.
And I think of
our colleague, Ian Condry,
who has this book on Japanese hip-hop,
and he has this diagram of a pyramid,
you could also think of it as an iceberg,
where there's a few people,
you're on the top of the iceberg.
You're above the,
You're above the waterline,
but there's so much going on
that people are playing in
clubs or people are just
freestyling in their living room or
on the street or whatever else.
And so that stuff underneath the surface,
being able to be in
communication and be out
is also really intriguing to me.
And those are things involved
with computing technologies,
whether or not they're
super sophisticated innovations
in transformer-based LLMs.
- Yeah. There are so many
threads that have been unpacked.
So if I can go back through
them, I guess, one at a time.
So in terms of hip-hop
culture and rap music being valued,
well, I thought you were referring to more
capital C culture, lowercase
C culture kind of divide.
When it first came out and people...
were early '80s.
I mean, it came out in the
early, I mean, in the '70s,
but then in the early '80s,
in the news you'd hear
these sort of things like,
"Is it really music?"
I mean, just ridiculous
arguments.
So yeah.
But I understand that's
not really your focus.
Then we moved into discussing the value
of freestyle.
And that means both
the way it's culturally
esteemed in general
within various hip-hop
communities and economically
too
by so many different criteria.
And I thought it's not just a matter
of the platforms that we have now.
'Cause if I think back to, say...
We were speaking about
undergraduates earlier,
when I was an undergraduate,
There was one, there was
a hip-hop album and rapper
that I liked a lot,
which was Saafir and his
album "Boxcar Sessions".
And I was living in the Bay area,
so I would see people from...
His crew was called Hobo Junction.
So I mean, they were just selling
their mix tapes and
things just on the street,
and the way...
I mean, so he, I mean, he had a CD out,
and I mean, was relatively popular,
but not mainstream popular.
But what we began to hear was
an apocryphal story about Saafir
versus the entire Hieroglyphics
crew on some radio show
and what happened there.
And I mean, I'll leave it to
people to go look that up,
look that up themselves.
And I mean, actually esteemed
both Hobo Junction and the Hieroglyphics,
but
it was interesting,
particularly as someone
that appreciated Saafir's recorded work,
but then hearing the story
about what he was capable of
in terms of freestyle.
That was something that I
felt for the people I knew
that increased the value of
everything that he was doing
by knowing the full range of abilities.
In terms of
generating
content, regardless of what kind it is,
we spoke about visual arts,
we spoke about rap and more,
I think about...
We've spoken about the Argentine
writer, Jorge Luis Borges,
and the story, "Pierre Menard"
is one that comes to mind.
So for people who aren't familiar,
this is a story of somebody who
is writing what he thinks of
as the great literary work
of the time, in a way.
And it ends up being "Don Quixote",
not because "Don Quixote"
was, in its own time,
a great work, it was as if
he was just conceiving of it at that time
with no reference to the prior work.
And it meant something
completely different.
Because if somebody wrote that book now,
it would mean something totally different
than it meant at that time period.
And so he was just thinking
how groundbreaking it was.
And I think generated rap is like that.
If you had some generated...
I mean, generated content in general,
like the artist you mentioned
who had been training
in some
art historically grounded way
according to certain
traditions since youth.
And if that person were to violate
some assumption made
in figurative artwork,
then people would say that is
intentional and for a reason.
And maybe that's a deviation
for what they've done in the
past that people didn't like,
but maybe it's something like, look at
this new development in their work.
And I've seen the same thing happen
with digitally created work,
even in some of my own
digitally created poetry
when I was in graduate school.
If people thought a computer generated it,
they would think,
and there was repetition,
they would think there must
be a flaw in the algorithm
because it's repeating the same thing.
If you have something like
Edgar Allan Poe's "The Raven",
people don't think
that "Nevermore" is just
a bug in the system.
I mean, it's intrinsic to
the structure of the poem.
And I think it's like that.
If you had something where
you had a rapper that...
Such and such rapper
that's known for doing
innovative things, uses AI
to create their works,
then people might take it in one way.
If somebody is known for doing,
say,
what people think of as highly commercial,
almost disposable kind of work,
and someone said,
"You know what? Their
rhymes are generated by AI."
People might say like,
"But that's horrible.
Why are they just, Why
are they just doing that?"
And it could be the exact same verse,
but people take it in a
totally different way.
So I just think it's
the setting, the person,
all those things play a role
in how things are being taken.
So in our task of creating
rap lyrics that
we say what would be highly valued,
it's a major challenge to
say under what criteria,
under which settings
and so forth.
I mean, just to give one more example.
And I think (indistinct)
you could say more about it,
but I think there's some
different philosophies.
I know some
underground hip-hop,
where it's
almost like the MIT students,
that Nick mentioned earlier,
were having as many syllables as possible
and obscure references
and making it all work,
all that.
And that's why
they think like, "Wow, that
person's a really great rapper."
And then there's the moves the crowd idea.
And then you say like, "What?"
And then some people do both.
And then it's hard to
say under which criteria,
what makes somebody
the best in a way.
It really depends under which criteria,
what they're trying to
do, what the audience...
I mean, there's so many factors.
And so, to me, that's what
the "Pierre Menard" story
is a parable of, is that phenomenon,
how much context and culture.
I mean, all those things matter
for how we interpret works.
- Yeah.
I mean, when you mention about
maybe this deviation from good art
is something interesting
reminds me to paraphrase Picasso,
children know how to draw
like a child already.
The problem is getting adults to do that.
How can adults learn to do that?
But I guess there's something about
the child-like perspective on the world,
and
drawing like a child,
whereas the question is,
there is an issue,
is what the generative model
is doing as a writer, for instance,
is that really interesting
because it's being like a very assertive
plagiaristic high school essayist
making up the quotations
from someone and making up citations.
And it's like...
I mean, the thing that I
think is interesting about...
One of the things that I think
is potentially interesting
about generative models
and large language models is that
you can tell something about
all of the language they've ingested.
It's like the surrealist wanted to get
into their own unconscious.
They wanted to do automatic writing,
and they wanted to surface
some of the things that they wouldn't have
written
in normal circumstances.
And so maybe these models
are a way of surfacing the
collective unconscious,
but the super ego
of ChatGPT's reinforcement
training is beating that down
so that we'd actually don't
have anything offensive.
The system has to tell you what it knows
and what it doesn't know.
So it's actually the...
I just
want
the language model that's
pure id if we're gonna,
(laughs)
if we're gonna find out
about this type of stuff.
- Evil GPT?
- Yeah.
Well, that's the thing.
I mean, people also...
There's prompt-injection
attacks and there's
how do we
do anything now and all these.
So I think that's one of the things, is
what you do with these models as an artist
may or may not align with the
interest and plans of the
people who made the models.
Because,
to some extent, it's like we want to build
a better customer service representative.
That's the goal.
Or something to entertain you
online.
And so maybe that's not the
idea of tapping into the
collective unconscious
and doing something that's really radical.
- Well, I think it's a matter of being
culturally responsive.
And so for example,
that's what made Duchamp's
readymades interesting,
that is
if
an AI system, you wanted to
create some great artwork,
and then it brings you a bicycle tire
or something like that,
you might just think it's
a failure of the system.
But if it's something
that would scandalize the
art world at that time
in a particular kind of way...
Or to give a personal example,
when I was in art school,
and I had a very
traditional drawing teacher
who thought you needed to learn
the fundamentals of figurative drawing,
and then you can do
anything, conceptual artwork,
other sort of things,
but you thought you should
know the fundamentals first
and then do other sort of things.
And I actually quite liked his class,
so it's not just putting
down that approach,
it's just one approach,
but
the point here is when
doing, say, renaissance-style
drawing and perspective
and lighting and shading
and the push pull of light
and dark, (indistinct),
all these techniques.
And I remember doing a
portrait in that style,
and a graduate student who
didn't share that point of view
that looks at the works.
And so what I did was intentionally...
Because
the questions I would
get were the ones, say,
playing a role-playing game.
And if I were to play, say,
a fantasy role-playing game,
and I always play as a
Legolas type character.
People say, "But you're not like that.
Why are you playing that character?
Do you wanna have long blonde hair?
Do you wanna look that way?"
That sort of thing.
And yeah.
So they're thinking like,
"What is my role in society?
How does that relate to me?
Is it a active imagination
that I could play
as that character?
Is it something, Is it self-hatred?
What is it? What's going on?"
And so it was like that
using renaissance-style
drawing when I did it
compared to, say, if we had an
exchange student from Italy,
it would be seen in a
totally different way.
So I thought, "Okay,
well, I'm gonna go all in,
and I'll draw myself in
renaissance apparel.",
and all these things,
and make it really obvious.
And then that question would come,
and people say, "Why are you doing this?"
That seems so Eurocentric."
And I'm like, "Well, that's the point."
It's like I'm responding to
what the education is showing us,
and what is my position in it.
I have to negotiate it in some way.
So that was responding
intentionally to what I was doing.
If a system just developed
that was putting everybody
in renaissance clothes
no matter what, then it
would be less interesting
than my intentional
decision as a subversive act
to draw myself in that way
because of the questions I was getting.
- Actually, that sold for a
lot of money at Christie's.
(laughs)
- It could be responsive
to this cultural moment.
So it just depends on whether it is,
or whether the story about it
is responsive to that cultural moment.
- That's where my mind is.
I think the story about it.
I think the meta-narrative around, even as
we're doing it right now,
will dictate how it's
appreciated, its use cases.
We may even just completely
forget about what it does.
It could just be sitting in a corner,
just generating the same
or just a continuous stream
of what have you,
of
neuronal thought.
But I think it's more
how are the critics gonna talk about it?
How are the,
How do the artists
annotate their own work and
position their own work?
Even in my class,
there's a balance, where
I'm more interested
in what you think about your
own work than the work itself.
All of the processes
and the steps you took to get to the work,
and your ability to explain it.
So I'm like, what's more valuable?
Yeah, your ability to
perform it is one thing,
but, again, it could be a bicycle tire
and all that that entails.
But I want to know what it entails.
And I think that's where the value,
a lot of the value
of AI and generative models is gonna be,
is the stories that we position
around the things that it creates
in addition to the story
that we talk about,
the technology itself, even if
the technology didn't exist.
'Cause we were...
There were stories around AI
before AI even existed in a way
for us to really participate in it.
So I think Skynet and the
Terminator and stuff like that.
(laughs)
And
it's almost like,
it's almost like a casino thing.
I think some people are gambling
just long bets about my
story's gonna be the story
that's gonna be the true one about AI.
And it's like, no,
my story's gonna be the
true one about AI, etc.
That part about, you
said the story about it
and the meta narrative I
think is also of interest.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
I think so.
The very first PhD
student that I graduated
named Jichen Zhu, her
PhD dissertation with me
was on what was called a
hermeneutics of AI systems.
And so, basically, the interpretation,
the experience of AI systems,
and one of the things we spoke about
and wrote about was it's not just a matter
of the technical function of the system,
we looked at other aspects such as,
does it have human-like coherence?
That was one criterion.
Does it seem to have intentionality?
Does it seem like it's about
the world within the world?
Those sort of things.
And so we had other types of criteria,
and then also the language
used to describe it.
So if you have
an algorithm
that is described as
something like a combination
of several letters and a number,
and then people don't,
but people don't know...
Some people know what it does,
but a lot of people don't
know what the system does.
If you have another system
that you call a machine learning system,
if you have another system you call
a case-based reasoning system,
and whatever names,
some of those names
make it sound like they're
doing something very human-like,
and if you say it's
doing something like...
Now we just call it it's
like a heuristic algorithm.
It's a really simple.
But like A star,
that's one of the first
algorithms I learned in AI
course.
It's a
search algorithm,
or something like Eliza did.
- Well, I mean, even search
sounds intelligent nowadays
because it's like, "Oh, yeah.
Google search, Bing search."
No, no, this is...
No, this is not this.
This is just like,
"Okay, we look down here,
then we look down here,
then we look down here."
Like that.
- Yes.
So what we looked at was also
the role of that language
in creating
the impression of AI systems.
And we weren't just saying
that it was something like a falsehood
or it was misleading
to say learning system
or that sort of thing.
But rather what role
does that language play?
And so what we found was
by analyzing the papers people
wrote about the systems,
technical, published papers,
there were some points
where people would just
describe the algorithm,
other points where people would say things
like learning system and
these sort of things.
And it might have helped
people to understand
what their objectives were better,
what they were trying to accomplish,
how it could be used.
And those sort of...
I don't think they were
just trying to fool people
to say like,
"Well, this algorithm is
learning like a human child.",
or something like that.
But it goes to show
that the story about it,
even in very technical work,
plays a huge role in how
people understand the work.
And yeah.
So I think not just for
these extreme examples,
but even for everyday
practice of technical AI,
the story that's being told plays a role.
And it's important to be
able to tell that story
in a way that's understood
by the community.
- There's a
former member of the Italian parliament
who suggested that instead of
AI, artificial intelligence,
you call these systems
systematic approaches to
learning and machine inferences.
And so you'd be asking questions like
can this salami write rap?
(laughs)
Should this salami be given human rights?
The meat of (indistinct)
(laughs)
Yeah, exactly.
So I think that's true,
the naming, the framework,
these are important issues,
and also being aware that
there's certain things.
It's like
if you just have a
probability distribution
over sequences of words
then it can do amazing things
that we didn't realize it could do.
And very coherent, very amazing outcomes.
But
not everything.
(laughs)
When I think about people who
want to engage with computing
and do things in creative ways,
a big piece of my advice is
still learn how to program
because the prompt engineering,
the idea that your job is gonna be done by
emerging technologies,
and you don't have to know
explicitly how computing works,
as we've been talking about, actually,
you're probably gonna be taking
some different approaches.
You're probably gonna be
wanting to do certain things explicitly.
There's people who are writing
very small processing programs
to do really interesting visual sketches,
there's people who are
doing other things with AI,
but you want to have the
range of those capabilities.
- The question we just got
was what kind of advice
would we leave people with?
And to the extent that with
these emerging developments,
I'm the person to give advice.
I would say this,
that when thinking about
technologies such as
AI for creative practice
and developing artwork,
creative cultural productions,
there are two criteria
that people often have
that I don't think are necessary.
One of these is the idea
that we have to make
the output human-like,
and that's what Nick was
mentioning just a bit earlier.
And I think we can do
all sorts of creative
generative
works,
produce all types of system
that don't have that kind
of criterion as end goal.
The other thing that people tend to assume
is that we often need
fully autonomous systems.
I think we can instead think about systems
that work collaboratively with us,
that work in improvisational ways,
that work in response to
broader cultural trends
to what's bubbling up online and more.
And I think we'll come up
with a lot of creative ideas
and possibilities when
we think about AI systems
in a way that relaxes
those kind of constraints.
- And my advice,
probably a little bit,
what's the word for it?
It's probably-
- Contrary?
- Not even contrary.
(laughs)
It's deeper than contrary.
Combative.
- Rebarbative.
- Reductionist, extremely reductionist is
don't use it.
(laughs)
To your point about programming,
learn how to program, learn how to write,
learn
the programming that is
traditional, classic, or
contemporary writing styles
or art styles.
There's still a lot of
opportunity for innovation
on just classical, analog things
that actually, I think,
AI and generative models
will shed light on,
which will show you things
that were in the shadows
that once the light in
the sun that is AI shines,
is gonna shed light on these
very classical traditions,
these very analog traditions
that still will generate things of value,
cultural products of value
and new skill sets
to be developed and deployed.
So I think there is
something to embracing in it
in a collaborative way, to
understanding it in a deeper,
below the surface type of way,
but also focusing back on the human
aspects and the human skill sets,
and still doing the work
of the traditional schools
and the formal practices
and things of that nature
from a computational
side to an artistic side.
That would be my advice.